bientôt les vacances et pour profiter du
soleil
rien de plus agréable qu'une décapotable
mais les nouvelles exigences de sécurité
ne vont-elles pas condamner le vrai
cabriolet volkswagen répond par la
négative
en donnant une suite à la coccinelle
construite par le carrossier karman la
golf décapotable reçoit 130 kg de
renforts structure avant entourage du
pare-brise cadre de portes arceau de
sécurité
traverse arrière
[Musique]
et cadres support de capotes
et pour la sécurité en cas d'accident
jugez vous même
la route est très efficacement les
passagers dans un et même plusieurs
tonneaux
[Musique]
avec la golf v a voulu comme pour la
coccinelle réaliser un véritable
cabriolet facile à décapoté
[Musique]
tout d'abord désarmer le clic et de
sécurité
[Musique]
ensuite relevé puis repliez
et enfin poser la housse de protection
[Musique]
certes cette capote fait un peu
volumineux et gêne considérablement la
visibilité vers l'arrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais juger de la qualité cinq couches
épaisseur totale 2 cm pour une isolation
thermique et phonique exceptionnel quant
à la vitre arrière
elle est en verre est doté d'un
dégivrage électrique peu de changements
à l'intérieur avec un tableau de bord
bien équipé et des sièges traité contre
les intempéries
mais la traverse de renforts avant gêne
un peu
et bravo pour l'arceau qui permet aussi
de mieux positionner les ceintures de
sécurité et d'offrir des vitres arrière
descendante
[Musique]
par contre la malepère and accessibilité
et en contenance bien que le dossier du
siège arrière restera battable
[Musique]
motorisation 15 170 chevaux ou 16 cents
injection 110 chevaux enfin preuve de
l'étude sérieuse de ce cabriolet
vv à réaliser des bars porte tout
spécialement adapté à l'heure où la
véritable décapotable disparaît
félicitons vv de donner une succession
au cabriolet coccinelle avec la golf
traction avant bien plus sur ce
cabriolet offre quatre vraies places ce
qui est rarissime et sera commercialisé
dans quelques jours à partir de 46 1500
francs avec possibilité de boîte
automatique
[Musique]